hey hey just now what was going on good
how are you doing Danny I'm doing
wonderful i love hey Peter Brown came on
the set and drop the by no one who's
ever thus making your inclusion on the
show redundant I know why am I even here
good to see Justin next up folks we're
heading well the reason I was late is
because I was checking out farmville in
virtual reality is really cool that's a
lie can't wait for you trying to say
that because you signed the journalists
code people will believe you Alison I
mean on the hour so there was a really
big I don't know if you'd call this
bombshell but a really interesting story
this morning there is a a graphics panel
of a graphic you know graphics
processors you're doing a panel here in
San Francisco they reveal nvidia
revealed the gtx titan z so you know i
think a lot of us here in the office we
have Titan graphics cards they're good
they're several hundred dollars this one
is three thousand dollar okay I'll wait
isn't it is a three-thousand-dollar card
it is basically giving you a
supercomputer in a compact form that no
regular person would ever need I mean it
costs more than a used car My gods what
do you what what is what programs are
going to be taking advantage of this no
program is say I mean there is no game
there's nothing that that we would need
for something like this this is purely
for for guys who are n Pixar and need a
portable solution for making a movie at
home are hobbyists that enjoy rendering
artistic things that depreciate by 50%
minute they take them out of the box say
you know I imagine some people are just
gonna get a quad sli set up really
quickly with four of these like so
twelve-thousand dollars that's
reasonable no problem yeah and then
crank up arma 3 22 top graphics alright
that seems insane and rolling around you
might need with this graphics card for
another game that was announced it was
kick-started and it was a successful
Kickstarter I bear bear simulator three
yes I saw there's something there one
yeah it's the first one continuing the
trend of awesome goat and other animal
theme I feel like you later yeah I don't
know go two million next week I was
pretty rad that goats in manners coming
out I feel like we're there's like it's
is like the web bubble of the early
2000s where we now have this like
animals stimulator bubble there's too
many games coming out explain to me why
I should play bear simulator well as you
can see you
walk around is kind of like a zombie
bear of interacting with the world
around you looks really good look at
those water physics they're so wonderful
italy lies thing is it tighten if you
worry but if you were a bear and you had
on two arms that's how you do awful that
trout you can also go in hibernate okay
great and that's how you get your energy
back to go like kill ought to feel is
gonna swap some butterflies later steal
honey Frankie's and I think on a serious
note for serious though I think that
animal simulators are something that
could be super awesome for oculus for
VAR because listen like you're talking
about experiencing the world in a
different way by encompassing your
entire vision and like the way you look
at the world and the way you move
through the world I think that that
would like are you watching an episode
of planet Earth and I imagine if you
could like looks like one of those
scenes as that animal that would be dope
could you imagine like wasps emulator
and it's got like the oculus but it's
got those like 9i thing going on you
don't fly around yeah and you get is so
instantly barf to regress like 20 years
in terms of your actual human
functionality but it would be cool to do
the Kickstarter for this was like 20
grand that it's all yes oh no he's
looking for 20 and they've already got
43,000 still 20 days to go so don't
pretty care how much of an accurate bear
simulation do you want internet oh and I
was your time super handling him money
and we'll see what I want to eat some
garbage out of a trash can and the final
bit of news the most the interesting bit
of stuff that came out yesterday is that
a lot of stores have been dropping the
price on the Xbox one out dropping the
price it's still a sale price you can
get an xbox one with titanfall they
essentially free for four hundred fifty
dollars at best buy and amazon and now
the official microsoft store is offering
the same deal kidding it not an official
price drop it have to put it in your
cart and then you see the price go down
but I mean that's essentially even micra
that Microsoft is also offering the same
deal yeah and also on the 425 bundle
they're essentially saying this is
overpriced and we're going to give you a
discount on it wow it's 110 dollars then
off what that would be if you purchased
yet on soul in the game because normally
is 500 normally the game would be 60s
you're getting a game for free it's
technically cheaper than up
is for at this point yeah with a gate
cuz you're getting the game and it's an
awesome game so it's not like some chump
game it's friggin titanfall like yeah
although you have a PlayStation Plus
subscription on your ps4 you get réseau
gun some other nice to I mean it's no
tire fall that's true it's no time for
hey to each their I mean those games are
each have awesomeness in them so if
you're on the fence went by an xbox one
it appears that now there has never been
a better time to purchase an Xbox
literally but there might be a better
time in the future so you might want
probably dozens of though it's probably
going to be a load more better times to
purchase Xbox one black friday will
probably be pretty good yeah you should
probably wait until November yeah what
do you although you probably have other
life endeavors to get on with you could
probably just play diablo until then
Justin hey well thank you very much for
joining us thank you I need to get back
to farmville go do it